-Hi. I'm Jimmy Fallon
and welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
It's Freaky Friday tonight.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hey, did you hear the big news
about Mike Pence?
You remember him, right,
Casper the Homophobic Ghost?
[ Laughter ]
Mike Pence released
a policy agenda,
which is a strong indication
that he plans to run
against Donald Trump in 2024.
Pence versus Trump.
Wouldn't that be something?
Like Logan Roy
versus Cousin Greg.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Fox News
just announced
they've hired Caitlyn Jenner
as an on-air contributor
to their channel.
Fox put out a press release
that said,
"Caitlyn's story
is an inspiration to us all.
She's a trailblazer
in the LGBTQ+ community
who will not be allowed to use
the bathroom at our office."
[ Laughter ]
You know, I love being here
in New York
and I want to tell you
about this crazy thing
that happened in L.A. last week.
So, you know the actor
Will Smith?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, you've heard this story?
Okay. I didn't know
if it made it east,
so, I'll skip it, then.
[ Laughter ]
Are you figuring out
what's happening now?
You're noticing what day it is?
Or no. Maybe. I don't know.
April Fools, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Show of hands.
How many of you
are disappointed?
Be honest.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, how many are very
disappointed? Be honest.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And how many of you
are thinking,
"Oh, my God, Jimmy Fallon
looks terrible.
I hope he isn't sick"?
[ Laughter and applause ]
We pulled the old switcheroo.
In fact, right now,
Jimmy F-word,
as we call him back home,
[ Laughter ]
is hosting my show in L.A.
We swapped everything.
We swapped shows, bands,
even wives.
Bad news, Nancy --
Fat Jimmy's coming home.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
This is something we've been
planning for a long --
for years.
It was a top secret operation.
Even The Roots didn't know
this was happening
until today, right?
-No idea.
-Jimmy doesn't trust you,
is what --
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations on that Oscar,
by the way.
Questlove won an Oscar.
-Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Nobody in my band has an Oscar.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Not yet.
-And I have to say,
your movie is fantastic
and your speech was beautiful.
Actually, I watched it as soon
as I stop rewinding 500 times.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations.
Everybody here has been so nice.
I got to meet Jimmy's writers.
I got to meet his producers.
His security guy
took me on a tour.
I even got to meet the chef
who cuts his chicken nuggets
into dinosaur shapes.
[ Laughter ]
Wonderful guy.
It's exciting to be here.
This is really
I always dreamed of hosting
a late night talk show
and now, that dream
[ Laughter ]
has finally come true.
Should we check in on Jimmy
to see how it's going
in Hollywood?
-Yeah!
-Yeah?
[ Cheering and applause ]
It was a rhetorical question,
really.
You don't have a choice.
I'm checking in with Jimmy,
either way, but -- Oh, hey,
there's Jimmy right now.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-And see how he's doing.
Jimmy, are you there?
-I'm here.
I'm in your place.
[ Whistling ]
-Yo!
[ Laughs ]
-Is this weird?
We did it!
Wow!
-Jimmy.
A big chunk of your audience
almost left when I walked out.
[ Laughter ]
I saw sadness.
-Yeah, for the first time,
tonight I got a great
sitting ovation.
[ Laughter ]
It was unbelievable.
How's it going over there, bud?
You look great.
-It's going well.
Everybody's been great
and I went through your stuff
and everything,
so, thank you
for letting me do this.
We've been talking about this
for a long time,
I was just telling everybody.
-Right? April 2020.
-April 2020
is when we conceived this.
[ Laughter ]
-That's wild.
And do you like the studio?
Do you enjoy it?
-Not really, no.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, no, yeah, it's beautiful.
It's absolutely beautiful.
It makes me realize
what a dump our place is.
[ Laughter ]
How about Guillermo,
is he alright?
Is he doing okay?
-Guillermo's okay.
C'mere, c'mere. C'mere, bud.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, I have Guillermo.
He's doing alright.
He's okay.
Guillermo.
-Hi, Jimmy!
-You look good.
-Yeah, he's okay.
-Guillermo, did you remember
to take your vitamins?
-Yeah, I did.
Took my vitamin tequila.
-Okay, good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He did, yeah.
Is Higgins there as well?
-Yeah, Higgins is right here
also, actually. He's --
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
He's freaky.
-I put on a mustache
so you'd feel at home, you know.
-Thank you!
-Grew a mustache.
-That's nice.
It's a great look for you.
-Good to see you, Higgins.
-Higgins looks like
he should be swindling widows
out of their fortune.
[ Laughter ]
-Flimflam, I say!
-Guillermo,
I'll be home tomorrow.
If you need anything
before that, call Ellen, okay?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Alright. I will, for sure.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know --
-This is wild, bud.
It's been an amazing experience.
I love that we did this.
I can't believe
we pulled it off.
I really can't believe it.
We did it. We pulled it off.
-I'm still not sure of how both
of our musical guests
are Red Hot Chili Peppers,
but I guess we'll figure
that out at the end of the show.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah. Yeah, that's right.
Red Hot Chili Peppers are both
of our musical guests tonight.
Their new album is out now,
at this point.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Alright, have fun.
-Jimmy, this is magical.
I love it.
I love talking to you, bud.
-Yeah, this is a lot of fun.
And I especially love talking
to you over a satellite.
It's even better that way.
[ Laughter ]
-I agree. Alright, well,
I think we we should move on
with the show, alright?
What do you think?
-Yes. Okay.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, great.
-Let's move on, yeah.
-Alright.
You want to hang up?
-No, no, no, no, no.
You hang up first.
-No, you hang up.
Come on, you hang up.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you hang up first.
-No, you hang up!
-No, you hang up.
No, you hang up.
-We'll hang up at the same time,
alright?
Ready?
1, 2, 3.
-2.
-Oh, well, we got it
all screwed up.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
-Oh, he did hang up.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I'll see you at home, Jimmy.
Alright, well,
that's Jimmy Fallon in L.A.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's going to be fun.
Don't be bummed.
Bridget Everett is with us.
We have music from
Red Hot Chili Peppers tonight.
And, from "The Music Man,"
the toast of Broadway,
Hugh Jackman, Wolverine himself,
is here with us.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Or maybe it'll turn out to be
Hugh Grant.
Who knows?
Anything is possible tonight.